to LeBron James and now and so that's
that's so wild it's such a huge it's
huge on so many levels was there any
talk of Kobe coming back to play with
him
Kobe knows that anytime he wants to come
and do anything for the organization
he's more than welcome he he was
somebody that I leaned on in the last
couple years in terms of you know just
picking his brain he might be one of the
the best strategists I've ever spoke to
yes and you know his ability to dissect
to the smallest detail but also see the
bigger picture and take take the camera
back and really take in the whole
situation you know he is he's a valuable
resource to me and somebody that is
someone I admire respect both on and off
the court he's a hard worker he's a hard
worker yeah yeah
maybe the hardest you think he's one of
the hardest-working players that ever
played for the Lakers yeah I mean you
know when you have a guy that is you
know a veteran with that kind of success
being the first one to practice every
day yeah that sets the bar you know
everybody else how can the best player
on the team be here before you you got
to work harder I mean he he just brought
that kind of element to the team did it
seem like this is a regular fan it
seemed like he's like at the end it just
seemed like there was like he like he
took so much of the more like the money
and the business there was no money for
anybody else you know that that's not
fair to look at it that way that you
know and that's an intellectual that's
an unknowable fan saying and then I'm
happy to have the opportunity to kind of
fill in you know so you see the whole
picture but yes it's you know in the NBA
we have a salary cap which everybody
hears about but we also have a salary
floor like you there's a minimum amount
you have to spend and then it's not that
big of a difference between so
somebody's going to get the money right
and so really Kobe for the the the
amount of weight on the team
that he pulled right he deserved that
money right so I have no problem with
that
would you be shocked if Kobe came back
to play with LeBron I mean I think his
wife would you know his wife Alicia she
would be mad at me but you know it's
like you know Kobe has to do what's in
Kobe's journey you know and I I couldn't
twist his arm to do it but he if he
wanted to I would make sure it happened
you know it's it's really up to him and
and you know we retired both his numbers
last year in a ceremony that was
difficult for me because he's somebody
that I I don't think I can ever
completely show my gratitude really -
yeah I mean he really wanted the you
know the biggest influences on my life
and you know what he means to the Lakers
and you know I kind of you know it was
hard for him he didn't want to he didn't
want to go through that kind of ceremony
the he never really liked that kind of
attention he loved playing basketball he
loved winning basketball games but doing
all the other stuff was you know that's
just not his style Wow
do you uh do you feel like if there was
another job that Kobe got into what
would it be outside of sports well you
know he he has an oscar-winning film
producer now after his his movie his
short film was nominated he won in that
category and so I see him as a
storyteller as a creative person who can
you know bring things to life because he
the way he could break down detail and
and kind of absorb what was happening
and I mean you know their stories about
how he would study you know cheetahs and
how cheetahs would you know move stalk
their prey and how they would move and
how they use
their tale as balance and you know I
mean he just it's like that's a an
intricate mind that you know can capture
and and you know express and explain
things in an interesting way thanks for
watching that video right there that was
a beautiful little segment I think but
of course i'm partisan to myself but you
can move on to another video right now
you can check on this video or on this
video that's two different options and
you can also subscribe to the channel
check on a new video subscribe to the
channel check subscribe subscribe